[Musique]
madame monsieur bonsoir prêt de deux
heures d'une remontée triomphale des
Champs-Élysées 600 000 personnes
attendaient les Bleus cet après-midi sur
la plus belle avenue du monde les bleus
et leur entraîneur et mets Jacquet pour
un triomphe jamais vu et qui n'a même
pas plus terminé je vous disais sur la
Place de l'Étoile il y avait trop de
monde les malaises dans la foule et les
organisateurs ont préféré écourter le
trajet le récit de Pascal golemer et
Jean-Paul chaussée
il s'était donné rendez-vous en cette
belle après-midi d'été sur les
Champs-Élysées et quel rendez-vous
un moment exceptionnel un de plus
d'un côté les joueurs de l'équipe de
France voulait montrer à leur public
cette coupe du monde dont ils ne peuvent
plus se séparer
de l'autre le public ces dizaines de
milliers de supporters 500 000 600 000
peut-être de tous âges de toute trace
voulait dire merci aux Bleus merci à
Zizou à m'aimer et à tous les autres
l'autobus à impérial noyé dans la foule
n'avance plus guerre et l'Arc de
Triomphe est encore loin mais qu'importe
sourire et maintendue la victoire est si
belle à partager
[Applaudissements]
oublier le petit carnet de notes et les
consignes technicotactiques Aimé Jacquet
savoure l'instant
et il laisse assez joueurs le soin de
veiller sur la coupe il peut leur faire
confiance
tout le monde se dit merci tout le monde
se dit bravo et à la prochaine fois plus
question de se séparer
c'est une belle histoire d'amour entre
22 joueurs de football perché sur un
autobus et le peuple de France rassemblé
sur une avenue une histoire qui ne fait
que commencer
[Musique]